blls have closed in Iraq's first
provincial election in a decade but
beyond the question of who wins turnout
is being closely watched after Shia
political leader m s urged his
supporters to boycott the
vote if we don't participate in the
elections there'll be no change
corruption will
continue we need to change the general
situation of Iraq now the situation is
not like before we want it to improve we
hope this election is
successful s boycott call makes turnout
a referendum within the election one
that may indicate how much power he and
his movement still have well the turnout
at this bdad polling station is low it
may not reflect that of the entire
country and any big differences could
deepen the existing political deadlock
in Bagdad and the southern provinces
where Iraq's she Shia are concentrated
participation was limited in Sunni
majority provinces the turnout was
higher but all eyes were on kuk in the
north where the first provincial
election is being held in two
decades our main concern is The
credibility of the results there's still
forgery and when the results vary there
will be
problems according to official numbers
fewer than 40% of eligible voters
Nationwide participated in the election
Ali Hashim Al jaaz Bagdad